Modest.
I think one thing we've learned over the
last eight,
the obvious one is you can't bring
democracy at the barrel of a gun.
I mean I think people would have known
that in the first place that even the
Bush people don't say that they,
they,
that's what they sought to do though.
It's sure it looks like that's what they
sought to do.
The point is what can you do?
What can any outside act or including
the United States do to try to bring
more democratic outcomes in countries?
And I think there's,
I,
I tend to talk about it as a kind of
high thing in a low thing.
The low thing which happens with nobody
particularly noticing it is the slow
effort at building up institutions.
The state building part of this,
and,
and this is a key aspect,
but a,
a very gradual listic one where you try
to help countries with issues of rule of
law and transparency and limiting
corruption as well as helping to build
infrastructure and so forth.
That's the low thing,
the high thing and the dramatic thing.
Well,
these are public diplomatic acts.
So how can the United States make a
difference there?
Well,
there are some times when elections are
enormously consequential and it really
matters a lot for the United States to
come down on the right side.
Uh,
we saw recently in Pakistan and the
United States was on the wrong side and
the democratic civilian secular parties
succeeded anyway.
So it shows the limits of our power for
bad as well as for good.
But there are moments when are these
enormously important for the United
States to say there was a democratic
side and there is a not democratic side,
well,
less democratic.
And we stand with the devil
to take eight an example,
which I think is not the space you hear
people say,
Oh,
in the Middle East we have a tradition
of Islamic democracy.
We call it the shoe off,
which is to say a council of elders who
together reach a consensual conclusion.
Well,
that's not a democracy.
That does not represent the will of the
people.
And especially in a complex society,
uh,
as opposed to a tribal society.
Uh,
sure.
Art will not be a,
a useful reflection of people's will and
will not be sufficiently accountable to
them and will not be counterbalanced by
other powers as well.
So there's an example where I would say
the local customs don't get you there,
or the lawyer Jirga in Afghanistan,
they're very important transitional
devices,
but they're not the thing itself.
At the same time,
uh,
there are lots of elements of things
like how power is divided between the
center and the locality,
where the United States has a particular
way of doing it that's very different
from our western other Western
democracies,
much less in other African countries.
They are systems of,
of adjudicating a more traditional
systems of,
of,
of the,
of justice,
for example,
which can waive alongside more western
systems of justice.
So incredibly,
there is not a one size fits all aspect
of democracy,
but it's a big mistake to think that
it's so variable that there are not a
series of quite fundamental practices,
values institutions,
which aren't as essential for anybody.